πως μένα τους αριθμούς θα λέμε ότι πάμε πάρα πολύ καλά και είναι αλήθεια ότι
σε σύγκριση με άλλες ευρωπαϊκες χώρες είμαστε σε μια πολ καληφάσι η κυπριακή οικονομία πρέπει
να μαστεευχαριστημένοι όι ι πολύ καλή προπτική πέραν από τηη γείη βάσι και όχρημα τοπιστοτικό
στομέας και γενικότεριαριθμί δείχνουν ότι είμαστε σε μια σωστη πορία από τν άλλ όμως είμαστε
και εμείς πολίτες της κυπριακής δημοκρατίας δεν ζουμε απομονομένι νωρίζουμε πολύ καλά τα προβλήματα που
έχουν πάρα πολλτις συμπολίτες μας και η ακρύβια κι οπληθωρισμός αλλά γενικότερα η νέαταξη δεδομένων
γιατί θα πει κάποιος ότι ένας μεγάλος παράγοντας σημανικός παράγοντας ου έχειοθίσύγ κυπριαγικονομία σε αυτό
το επίπεδο που είναι τώρα είναι ξένες επενδήσεις και όλι η βεβαίως είμαστε υπέρτο ξενομε
πενδήσω από την άλλη όμως έχουν κάπως ανασταδώσει την κυπριακή αγορά είτε όσο αφορά το
κόστος διαβίωσης ίδδο κόςστός αγορα σε κατικίας αρα υπάρχουν προβλήματα δεν θέλουμε να ωραιο οποιούμε
τα πράγματα στην πραγματική οικονομία από την άλλη όμως ναι αν το δούμε σε ένα
χάει λεύρε δηλαδή σε ένα μια ανάληση το μάκρο οικονομικών κυπριακή οικονομία είναι σε πάρα
πολύ δυνατή φάση και σεωρις εσ και από την εμπηρία ότι η μεγαλύτερες προκλήσεις στο
κεφάλιο ικονομία το οποίο κια παράδειγμα έχει να αντιμετωπίσει μπροστάττο τώρα ο πρόεδος της δημοκράτειες
δύο πράγματα ξεκάθαρα τουλάχιστο για τ απόμενα δύοτρία χρόνια είναι δο θέμα ενέργειας και δεν
είναι μόνο το θέμα του κόστους που είνε βαι βεύως το προταρχικό αλλά και υπράς
είναι μετάβαση αυτά τα δύ όν μπορούν είνι ένα εκρικτικό μίγμα θα αποκαλούς γιατί από
τη μια το κόστος ενέργεια στην κύπρο είναι πολύ ψεη όλερο από άλλες χώρες της
ευρωπαϊκής ένωσης κυρίως λόγο τις έλλιψης φυσικόύ αρίου κι αυτό το θέμα με το φυσικό
αέριο τα κούμε εδώ και δεκαϊτίες και δυστυχώς δεν πάρθεηκαν τα μέτερα που έπρεπε να
έχουν παρθεί και από την άλλη σε συσχέτηση με το με την πράσινη μετάβασ έρχιεται
να μας δώσει ένα αμια